today we are looking at an object that
sounds remarkably simple but for me at
least when I first learned this it made
me realize that I thought I understood
this simple object and I realized that I
I didn't understand it as deeply as I
did and going into three dimensions
taught me that I didn't really
understand two Dimensions I just I just
had memorized a bunch of things and was
good at them memorize a bunch of things
and being good at them is a thumbs up
like I I like memorizing things and
knowing them well and I like being able
to do questions but that is not the same
as understanding how they work right you
can teach a year eight student to
memorize the quadratic formula and and
do it very very well and efficiently you
just just give them hundreds of
questions and they'll just put in a b
and c and they'll get things out and
they'll have no idea what they're doing
right there's no understanding and maybe
maybe you felt that when you learned
quadratic formula like you 10 or
something like that that's okay no
judgment
um but I want to I want to push past
that so to think about uh lines today
which is going to be the topic lines are
a very simple object maybe you feel like
you've got this down pat but I want to
try and um push and prod and expand your
understanding of lines
now we're going to do three-dimensional
lines right lines in three dimensions
and as we were talking about before
right an interval starts and ends
array starts and then goes forever
a line goes uh forever in both
directions now what that means is
a line itself strictly speaking is not a
vector because a line uh it does have a
Direction but it doesn't have a
magnitude or or its magnitude is
infinite which is which is not what
we're talking about when we say
direction of magnitude we mean finite
quantities right so in order to think
about lines in three dimensions I want
us to remember that pretty much
everything we've been doing in
three-dimensional vectors so far has
just started on what we knew from
two-dimensional vectors and
two-dimensional coordinates right so for
example just to review and I'd love you
to sort of go through the motions with
me when we think about coordinates we
would say oh we used to have just an X
and A Y
and we would say well just just have
another axis that's all you have to do
right what about with components how
would we normally write a
two-dimensional component form for a
vector
all right okay so I would have
um some amount of I and K so you might
say x amount of I if that was your unit
Vector in the um X Direction and then
you might say uh y amount of the unit
Vector in the y direction right and then
what did we do we just said okay we'll
just let's have another component right
let's be really really
um uh I why did I put why did I put K
we're going to get to that in a minute
um I'm getting ahead of myself uh why
don't we just put an additional unit
Vector just in another orthogonal
direction right so Z okay like so right
uh help me out here when we're working
out the distance to a point from the
origin or the magnitude of that right
how do we do that in two dimensions
and the distance formula what what is
the um what's the year seven and eight
piece of math that we use to work out
the distance formula
Pythagoras very good uh so it's going to
be the square root of the sum of the
squares of the two shorter sides which
are the X in the y direction and then
your hypotenuse is whatever right and
then we said well okay what happens when
we go into three dimensions and we just
did Pythagoras twice which gave us uh
you know something that looked very
familiar it's just that oh look we're
we're following the the pattern right
last one when we looked at the dot
product okay
um I'm thinking about the the components
when you've got x's and y's uh you you
just take each of them and you well it's
called The Dot product right so you
multiply across and then our equivalent
in three dimensions was what
yep the same in fact it's so the same
I'm going to be lazy uh like all
mathematicians are and add that in and
then say okay well we'll just have Z1 Z2
along the end okay
now
what I've just demonstrated here just to
review is that it has been stunningly
successful so far for us to just take
what we did in two dimensions and then
just like literally add a zed on include
a zed like square that thing as well or
or multiply that thing as well or just
include another component that is z okay
now does that logic work for a line
well if you have a think about what a
line would be in two Dimensions we do
have lots of different ways to State the
equation of a line right we've got uh
morning Tron we've got Point gradient
form we've got two point form we've got
um on and on and on right probably the
most overall form the most general
purpose one is one the one we call
general form right uh can you guys
rehearse for me what is the general form
of a line in two dimensions
oh okay so did you say y equals zero
sorry
and get all equals here oh yes sorry so
it all equals zero yes so you get
everything on one side all the X's all
the Y's any constant so I guess we would
say you know something like ax plus b y
plus C by convention we usually have a b
and c being whole numbers you just
multiply by whatever factor to make them
all whole numbers and then you get zero
okay so if we were to say oh what would
that look like in three dimensions
following this same kind of pattern that
we've used before it's it's very
tempting to say well I don't know just
just have all the stuff you had before
and then say well maybe I should just
multiply by an additional you know
constant coefficient of z uh we should
have another constant there and then
make that all equal to zero right now
this would be if you have a look here
right mathematics is so much about
following patterns and all I've done
here is tried to follow the pattern this
is a very reasonable thing to do
but do you remember I said to you before
these are simple objects I felt like I
understood these by the time I learned
about vectors but then I discovered that
actually I didn't really
and how I can tell is that if you really
understand lines then you'll be able to
tell me why it is that this
second I'm sorry the first hand equation
that has to give you a line
and this second equation
cannot possibly give you a loan if you
really understand how lines work then
you'll know why this one works and this
one doesn't in fact it can't okay now
just like you don't have to actually say
it but I do Wonder
um do any of you have any Instinct just
give me a yes or no like do you have any
have an instinct for why the first one
works but the second one doesn't I don't
actually want to know the answer that's
a bit of a spoiler I just want to know
do you have an idea yes or no
yeah sort of are we getting consensus
yes or not
yeah not really Sean what do you think I
didn't quite hear you
really drank a line yeah sure yeah yeah
I mean it it feels like it ought to Mrs
Iles you would give will you give me
like a tentative yes
yeah
and you're like oh I'm fairly good but
I'm like like definition alone sort of
goes from two like from one place to
another even if it continues through
that and by now third in I feel like
you're trying to get a third point and
that's not a line anymore yeah yeah okay
okay this is really interesting so your
instincts I think are hitting you in the
right direction because if I take two
points in space right
um then I can uniquely say what's
joining the two of them will be a lie no
matter where you put your two points
right but if I introduce a third Point
there's no guarantee that unless they're
collinear less like a freak of nature
happens if you add a third point in
there's no guarantee that there will be
a single line that goes through in fact
um there's there's going to be
infinitely many that don't right and so
that that instinct is correct what I'm
going to do is I'm going to prove to you
and it doesn't take that long actually
why the first one gives you a line and
therefore why the second one cannot okay
so to make this part easier let's
actually consider an example because
this is all like A's and B's and C's
it's we've gone straight to a
generalized form here and usually in
mathematics what we try and do is go
from the specific first and then
generalize okay so let's just consider
an example let's suppose wrong marker
let's suppose we have a line that we
know is a line in two Dimensions so I've
got some made up numbers here like this
right 2x plus y plus 5 equals zero okay
now
if uh you were you know early on trying
to learn coordinate geometry and you're
like what is this thing what does it
actually look like if you didn't already
know that it was a straight line uh what
would we do or to work out the shape of
something when we've got no idea what it
is we just try and substitute some
values in and see what happens okay so
I'd like us to do that and actually
because it's 3v this is perfect I'd like
you each to substitute in a different
value can we go x equals I'll let you
guys choose who's going to do what x
equals zero x equals one x equals two
we're going to get a y value
for each one
okay someone chose the easier one that's
okay
hmm all right it shouldn't have taken
that long who did x equal zero
and you got y equals negative five thank
you very much okay x equals one means y
equals negative seven negative negative
negative seven
yes negative seven of course yes so
sorry hold on yes okay and then lastly
sorry I just got confused for a second
because I negative nine okay fantastic
now by the way you should sort of expect
that because you're like oh even though
it's in general form it's not exactly
geared up for this you could probably
mentally rearrange without too much
difficulty to put this into uh say
gradient intercept form right and so you
can see the gradient is going to come
from this two but it's on the wrong side
at the moment so when you go over the
other side gradient negative two and
that's why we're dropping down so far so
good
now what we've got here therefore is
um each of these ordered pairs uh zero
negative five one negative seven and two
negative nine right this is a set of
points which if I continued it I'd get
an infinite set of non-identical points
that are arranged to give me a line can
I say that one more time right this is
an infinite set
of non-identical points
and when you string them together what
you get is a line
that makes sense right now if we
consider this same logic right let's try
and take this uh extended version of a
line without now this extra variable in
there right so again now let's think
about uh well instead of having just 2x
plus y let's throw uh I don't know let's
go three Zed in there okay and then I'll
just still have a plus five okay equals
zero
again I'd like you to and um let's let's
just for the sake of Simplicity keep the
the arrangement the same what happens
when you substitute a value in like x
equals zero x equals one x equals two
we get the number in terms of Z right
right so so you get why if you wanted to
get a y equals you'd have it in terms of
Z if you made by the subject right
um in fact you don't even need to do
that to sort of demonstrate the problem
here if I just uh substitute it in and
just leave everything on the left hand
side in the first instance I get uh y
plus three Z plus five equals zero in
the second instance what do I get y plus
three said Plus
plus seven and then it'll be plus nine
right
now have a look at these right
um up here I had this infinite set of
points
but over here I now have an infinite set
not of points but of what are these
things these are lines right this is an
infinite set of non-identical lines
and therefore when you put a bunch of
lines together and they're not the same
line because they're non-identical you
don't get a line you get a
plane right so what we have done is not
created a line we have created an info
set of lines that together create a
plane so this approach here of trying to
generate an equation for a line in three
dimensions doesn't quite cut it which is
so disappointing because we were doing
we were doing so well following this
pattern right and you're like yeah
everything is looking great and then
here you're like not forget it okay